hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay we're going
nowhere
okay I want I want in the wrong place
there's a keypad next to the elevator I
need to find keypad unless I found it
already maybe they might keep doing that
um another journal no okay hit no one to
my secret no one two three four maybe
there's a code in here three little
kitties okay three little kitties first
kitty go home to one on their merry way
3/3 three one two three maybe I gotta
stop pressing this gate for that okay
that was was obviously the wrong one
yeah okay let me take my more notes okay
okay now there's no numbers in all of
them so okay yeah I'll read that one all
right I'm a little confused as to where
I need to go
not exactly sure because I was running
screaming away from the horror that goes
elsewhere but okay oh this is the other
side okay maybe I'm coming alright this
was the ax-murdered room let me just
double check and make sure there's
nothing else in here no no lady oh okay
serves me right for checking the room
again okay that's going budge same no
hasn't changed okay leptin okay nothing
in there but the other door is like
broken off its hinges I don't know why
oh okay oh I'm an idiot it's just
another way I went uh yeah I came in
here I'm stupid I'm stupid okay so
ignore my stupidity I just wasted five
minutes okay something said about
getting to the basement so I don't know
what's right
oh okay here we go
oh okay oh okay all right
Oh didn't I come down here I do not like
this oh no no no no come on take that oh
man oh man oh oh my have a heart attack
I swear I swear this game's gonna give
me a heart attack
oh okay making progress somewhere I
don't know where oh I don't know
okay
okay say thank you okay save
oh boy where's Locke um basement key
okay Megan progress I'm surprised I'm
making progress because I have literally
no idea where I'm going or what I'm
doing
load I wish I could reload with one
wielding but make it too easy
oh come on reload the clip was in the
bug I found a bug oh it's down there Oh
Oh No
Oh what is wrong with you what's wrong
with you what's wrong with you
ah okay guy just guy you just bugs so
what's wrong oh okay I freaked myself
out there a whole lot more than I needed
to be oh god no no no no [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you nope nope nope no who's that bit oh
oh boy oh boy oh boy
nooses why nooses I'm gonna try to sue
subtly influence me
find a video player why I do not want to
see what's on this tape
honest-to-goodness oh I do not I do not
okay apparently I can't kill those women
those ladies sorry nope nope okay you go
girl not that scary you're pretty scary
but not that scary
I'll take you over the freaky lady's any
day
I don't want budge oh no oh no I lock
the lock okay with what I don't know no
no no no oh
why I just made a big circle what did I
get a videotape oh I got a videotape was
that
who's that oh I gotta find a video
player ah oh please no ladies anything
but those ladies they're like the kind
they're kind of like mannequins in that
they don't move and hit they're
terrifying
Oh give me your give me oh okay I got to
find a video player um I don't know
where I'm gonna find one it must have
been one in like the apartments or
something anything in here TV maybe this
okay all right Oh
sit on the couch all relaxed oh I'm
gonna die in seven days I'm gonna die in
seven days
okay looks like some torture going on oh
no that doesn't look good
oh all right off with his head
I didn't think it would be in such a
clean cut one seven seven nine thank you
thank you sir one seven seven nine oh
okay let's get the apartments with the
elevator why did I come in the
apartments why did that psycho maniac
who texted me and knew my number no oh I
don't care I don't care I'm okay I'm
just getting out of here I'm getting out
of here I'm just getting out of here one
seven seven nine seven seven nine
seventeen seventy nine is that reference
to like a number what the hell though
was it was it seven seven seven nine
that was a one yeah yeah I know
oh man oh I can't take this I got in an
elevator before where did that take
I'm okay I'm tough I'm super tough all
right that's a lot of blood that's a lot
of blood everywhere that's a lot of
everywhere blood again I'm just going
into worse and worse places how is this
escaping the apartment who did this is
this like a dream sequence
oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
they're funneling me they're funneling
me they're funneling me oh boy oh boy oh
boy
I don't like it I don't like it I do not
like it huh
but I'm tough I'm tough why so many
levels why why why why why
give me a lot of bullets I gotta fight a
boss
I hurt heart be okay I gotta cut it here
thank you guys so much for watching and
I'll see you in the next part maybe bye
bye